[Music]
how are you three weeks ago I went
golfing and beat my wife for the first
time those are two separate things I got
home she was like were you golfing again
and I lost it look I'm dressed like an
[ __ ] what do you think thank you my
wife has a PhD in genetics but that's it
she doesn't have a PhD and everything
even though you would not know that from
talking to her I think she's very smart
when she goes check what would you ever
do without me I'm a grown-up with a job
you heard what happened Conan said my
name I heard it I was like oh my god
that's me and I came out here all by
myself that's not true there's a guy
behind the curtain that holds your arm
till you're supposed to go and he came
out and put tape where I was supposed to
stand so the question is what would I do
without that guy and the answer is I'd
still be in my dressing room eating
cupcakes looking for the Funky Bunch you
know what I do without my wife I'd raise
my kids to be at least this old because
I've done it I've gotten like I've
gotten a human being to here that's why
it never made sense some people like I
could never have a kid I can't even keep
a plant alive well you're not a plant
you don't have to know how
photosynthesis works to keep a child
alive right
we just make your food and cut it
smaller very simple you cut up a steak
and put it in a plant you got a dead
plant on your hands they're just little
people I'm a big person I can help with
that because I've been there my
daughter's nine I've been a nine year
old person I know that's when girls get
real [ __ ] they hook their elbows
together and walk down the hallway you
don't have new shoes [ __ ]
I've been nine I can help with that it's
my son's 14 I've been there I told him
if you ever have to give a speech in
front of your class consider taping your
dick down that day we all know that
fourteen-year-old boners do not keep a
schedule I want you to know that my wife
is an outstanding mother which has never
been a teenage boy and I am very happy
about that so she has a lot of questions
for me she came in when he turned 30 she
goes we have a teenager now what are we
gonna do well we're gonna knock first
and foremost we were going to knock even
if the doors open I'd like you to reach
around and give it a tap because he
might be reaching around and givin it a
tap teenage boys are the most disgusting
creatures on the face of the earth
monkeys throw their own feces at you and
I'd rather have one of those living at
my place I don't trust anything in my
house I open the refrigerator with my
foot because I don't know if he had sex
so that when I wasn't home
and nobody should be disgusted by that
especially not the guys because all of
us got home from school before our
parents got home from work look at that
little space in between the couch
cushions and thought maybe oh that might
feel right
[Applause]
what is that velvet sometimes my wife
treats me like an idiot and I want you
to know that I have earned it
we're at the food court one day and she
goes I'm gonna go over here and get a
sandwich need some help getting the kids
some food
no I know how to buy food you jackass
looks like I'm walking up to the store
going I'll take one of those what's that
I need money
oh I didn't know that I'm just a dad let
me go get the mom she knows everything
can I leave the kids here do I have to
take him with me I don't know what to do
my penis doesn't let my brain work all
the way can somebody grab my wife she's
that one in the Cape it was at the food
court where there was only one set of
footprints because that's where she
carried me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]